today the Night wall show the internet
is very mad at me because I suggested
that criminals should actually be
punished for their crimes if you can
imagine it we will dive into this
provocative idea today also Mike Pence
is the latest former government official
to have classified documents in his home
apparently we all have classified
documents in our homes which makes the
media's narrative about Trump's
documents all the more absurd and an
MSNBC host contracts covid and laments
that he didn't get his fourth booster
shot to prevent it DeSantis is deemed
racist for coming out against the new
African-American studies curriculum for
public schools in our daily cancellation
we will learn why the word Aloha is
potentially insensitive bigoted and even
physically harmful all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
what if I told you that you could grow
your retirement nest egg without risking
it in the stock market Bank on yourself
is a better way to grow and protect your
hard-earned money this retirement plan
alternative has a 160-year plus track
record of Positive Growth Bank on
yourself guarantees predictable growth
of your hard-earned money with no luck
or skill or guesswork required your plan
doesn't go backward with the when the
markets tumble both your principal and
your growth are locked in and your
retirement income will be tax-free Bank
on yourself puts you in control this
concept allows you to access your money
for any purpose with no questions asked
and without government penalties or
restrictions you can't do that with a
401k or IRA so you can get a free Report
with all the details on how the bank on
yourself strategy adds guarantees
predictability and control to your
financial plan go to bankonyourself.com
Walsh that's bankonyourself.com Welsh
this information is for educational
purposes only is not a solicitation for
the purchase of any Financial product
all guarantees are based on the claims
paying ability of the insurer go to
bankonyourself.com Walsh today
we begin with some breaking news this is
not the sort of thing you expect to hear
you may find it shocking and certainly
upsetting I know I did but here's the
news people are mad at me on the
internet they are upset they're
scandalized they're calling me things
like fascist and bigot this is all of
course making me feel quite bad about
myself as someone who is so accustomed
to receiving unanimous Acclaim and
adulation and agreement all the time
everywhere I go so I don't know how to
deal with this
let's back up uh for a moment so you can
understand the context a few days ago a
leftist Twitter user and I inferred his
political leanings from the pride flag
in his bio
posted a video expressing his awe over
um the airport in Singapore
Singapore's airport as you can see it's
a rather impressive site it looks like
the uh futuristic Utopia in every sci-fi
movie right before the robots start
killing everyone and I mean that in a
good way
waterfall there is particularly
magnificent
um though In fairness I have seen
similar side set like LAX it's just that
those water flows waterfalls were
overflowing toilets our airports in
America are generally a different kind
of experience from what you just saw
there airports in the United States they
qualify as really nice if they have like
a food court with a Chipotle and more
than three electrical outlets in each
terminal so the bar is set a bit lower
admiring Singapore though has become
something of a trend online every so
often somebody usually somebody on the
left
will post a video uh like the one you
just saw or like this one extolling
Singapore the city for its uh clean
green
eco-friendly approach watch
this place creates Gardens and parks in
the middle of its buildings that's
because in parts of Singapore you're
required to replace the land that you're
building on with this same amount of
greenery so the greenery that is lost on
the ground is replaced in the sky each
building must have Greenery that's
equivalent to at least 100 percent of
the land that it was built on but some
take it to the next level this building
has over 200 percent Greenery for the
land that it replaced this is Park Royal
and it's absolutely crazy how they
manage to include Greenery throughout
the building you can even go on a garden
walk here but all of this is not just
done for a more beautiful look there is
a functional reason as well seat
buildings with more Greenery end up
using less electricity produce less
waste and in general have a lower carbon
footprint you also improve the air
quality and keep the temperatures cooler
this rooftop is over 50 stories high and
it's pretty much entirely a garden and
the crazy part is that it's completely
open to the public this is a public area
now your mileage may vary a bit with the
Jumanji aesthetic where forests are
growing inside and on top of all the
buildings the real point is that the
city looks bright and clean and safe and
not at all like a post-apocalyptic
zombie-infested hellscape which sets it
apart from our cities which in so many
cases look like some sort of horrifying
mashup of The Walking Dead and the wire
like this for example what you see here
is Philadelphia
but it could be a random street in
nearly any major American city
there's a reason we don't have you know
very many carefully manicured public
parks located on the tops of our
buildings because if we did there'd be
almost immediately you know a drug
addict passed out on every bench and a
homeless guy taking a dump in every bush
the people who look
with with envious lustful eyes at
Singapore's cleanliness and general lack
of fentanyl zombies and random street
thugs assaulting pedestrians have every
reason to be so Covetous when you
consider what our cities look like
but there's also a reason why Singapore
looks like Singapore in Philadelphia it
looks like Philadelphia
there are many reasons actually and not
all of them can or should be emulated
but in the Tweet they got me into
trouble I mentioned one major factor
that to my mind we should adopt I
tweeted this
Singapore is able to have nice things in
part because they execute drug dealers
by hanging and they arrest even Petty
vandals and thieves and beat them with a
cane until they bleed
we don't have nice things because we
aren't willing to do what is required to
maintain them
now that tweet has been viewed like 14
million times and 13.9 million of those
views apparently came from people who
were deeply offended by it on the right
and left
but offended as they may be the fact is
that Singapore isn't plagued by property
crime and violent crime nearly to the
extent that our country is in fact their
crime rates are among the lowest in the
world because
in part in large part they harshly
punish law Breakers
as mentioned in the Tweet thieves
robbers vandals similar malcontents are
subject to judicial caning drug
offenders can be given the same
treatment
and it's meted out to more serious
criminals like uh like rapists and
people convicted of kidnapping often the
corporal punishment will be paired with
a prison sentence which depending on the
crime can be quite lengthy
we've heard a little bit actually about
this punishment in Singapore and the
methods that are used from westerners
who have made the mistake of committing
the crimes in Singapore that everyone
knows you aren't supposed to commit in
Singapore for instance a couple of years
ago the British media reported with
great alarm about the story of a British
national who got caught dealing drugs in
Singapore
which again everybody even people don't
live in Singapore knows that Singapore
is the last place where you go to jail
drugs that's what he did and he received
20 years in prison to go along with a
caning that was so severe that he
couldn't sit down afterwards he had
trouble controlling his bowels because
of how badly he was beaten
he reported um that uh the the fear that
he felt and having to wait in line while
listening to the screams of other
inmates as they received their
punishments he's in one room waiting
this is the way he described it and they
bring people in one by one and they beat
them with the cane and you can hear them
screaming in agony and then they open
the door and it's your turn
not a pleasant experience
not one that I would ever want to
experience myself
but he got off easy compared to other
drug offenders because if in Singapore
you're caught with drugs over a certain
amount and it doesn't have to be all
that much 15 grams of heroin 30 grams of
cocaine for example you are
automatically charged with uh
trafficking drug trafficking it's
automatically assumed that you have that
because you want to traffic drugs
and in Singapore they simply do not
tolerate drug trafficking at all
so if you're convicted of drug
trafficking you are automatically
executed it is a mandatory sentence
and they will dull out this most severe
of punishments for you know a number of
crimes not just drug driving of course
murder terrorism kidnapping uh can also
warrant that and and other serious
crimes as well and the executions are
carried out usually swiftly death row
inmates are given four days notice not
four decades four days notice before
they're taken out usually at dawn and
they are dispatched by hanging
now it's often said that studies prove
that death penalty and other harsh
punishments are not effective deterrence
that's what we hear all the time in this
country it doesn't Studies have proven
Studies have proven it doesn't deter
anything
well seems to be working pretty well in
Singapore
which which in Singapore they can make
it through entire days okay in fact
dozens of days in a year without any
reported crimes at all
as a CNBC report marveled over uh
marveled over a few years ago Singapore
is so safe that many stores don't have
locks they don't lock their doors at
night and sometimes they don't even have
doors or locks to begin with
if capital punishment lacks a deterrent
element in our country it's obviously
because we hardly ever use it it's not
capital punishment itself it doesn't
deter crime it is the way that we go
about it
that lessens its deterrence Factor
there have only been something like 1500
total executions in our entire country
since the mid-1970s
and that number is decreasing all the
time
it's a small handful of people entire
across the entire country are executed
in any given year
and on the extremely rare occasion that
anybody is executed it happens decades
after the crime they committed out of
sight out of mind for the public and
after hundreds of appeals what this
means is that criminals they aren't
deterred by it because they know they
almost certainly won't receive that
penalty they know it won't happen to
them no matter what they do
it's not that they aren't scared of the
death penalty itself obviously anybody
would be scared of that is that they
don't believe the court system will have
the gumption to actually impose it on
them and in nearly every case they're
right
now when the death penalty or other
harsh penalties are immediate
and all but certain
it does have unsurprisingly a way of
dissuading potential criminals as it
turns out people do respond to
incentives and disincentives this is one
of the basic realities of of human
psychology is that every single person
on the planet responds to incentives and
disincentives
and the prospect of dangling at the end
of a rope until you die is a rather
powerful disincentive
it's not gonna be 100 effective
okay there are people who will risk it
but most people won't
for the pettier criminals the idea of
being stripped naked and beaten so hard
with a cane that the guy doing the
beating has to take breaks to let his
arm rest throughout your ordeal is also
a rather powerful disincentive
now our system of dealing with thieves
and vandals and those of that ilk is
laughably ineffective because in these
cases too the criminals aren't convinced
that there will be any significant
penalty and if they do wind up with a
short stint in prison the experience is
likely to only increase their street
cred and give them an opportunity to
spend time with and be influenced by
criminals even worse than themselves
but an added element of extremely
painful corporal punishment
creates a profound disincentive so that
even those unbothered by prison
would be bothered by this
caning is also and it is meant to be
humiliating degrading emasculating
which means that the experience isn't
going to enhance anybody's street cred
okay you're not going to get out of
prison bragging about getting caned
put another way it's not the kind of
thing that you can imagine a rapper you
know boasting about in a song
and that's precisely why it's an
effective form of punishment in fact
maybe this is like the easiest way to
think about this when you think about
what sort of penalty should we have for
criminals
think about it if it's the kind of
penalty you can imagine a rapper
bragging about in a song
that you know is becomes a big hit and
is and is and is uh streamed 100 million
times on Spotify if it's that kind of
penalty then it's not a good penalty
let's imagine penalties that they would
be too embarrassed and too ashamed to
brag about
those are the good penalties those are
the effective ones
now am I actually suggesting that we
should adopt these singapore-like
Draconian forms of Justice here in the
United States am I seriously advocating
that
yes absolutely of course I am corporal
punishment for convicted criminals that
shouldn't even be controversial okay
that's actually obviously the correct
thing to do
both both obvious and effective and just
those who cause damage to another
person's body or livelihood or property
should be made to experience the sort of
physical suffering that might help them
appreciate the seriousness of their
crimes
our current system is not impressing
anyone with the seriousness of their
crimes
that's what the punishment is supposed
to do
we have it in our heads that well all
forms of physical punishment are
automatically cruel and unusual I've
heard this over and over again as in
response to you know this argument well
it's cruel and unusual punishment
as if it's just self-evident you can't
you can't simply assert that it's cruel
and unusual to impose uh the death
penalty or corporal punishment explain
why you could call a cruel unusual
and in what sense is it either of those
things
I mean these punishments certainly
aren't unusual
on the contrary they are probably the
most usual sort of punishment imaginable
from a historical perspective
and they aren't cruel because the person
that they are inflicted on has chosen to
act in a way that warrants it
it is not cruel to assign undesirable
consequences to undesirable Behavior
it is on the contrary the only way to
maintain a civilized society
criminals and law Breakers must be made
to suffer if they aren't suffering then
it is not really a punishment
that's what a punishment is supposed to
do it's supposed to make you suffer
and so if we have a system where the
where the criminals are not suffering
then they're not being punished and we
are trying a system where we just
actually don't punish people for
committing crimes
now as for the death penalty for drug
traffickers this again to me seems
obvious they sell poison for profit
taking advantage of the most helpless
and miserable Among Us turning people
and entire communities into zombified
husks slowly dying while these parasitic
scumbags reap the rewards they deserve
to die for what they're doing to people
to our cities to our country
they deserve to die for it
fentanyl traffickers okay the people
that are those those zombies that you
saw in the in the clip of Philadelphia
that are they're walking around hunched
over
the people trafficking those drugs into
our communities they deserve to die I I
can't understand the argument to the
country you actually tell me they don't
deserve to die for doing that to people
do we need to keep them around
in what ways would we be harmed as a
society if the people that are doing
that uh if we are deprived of their
presence how are we harmed how are we
missing out
no our nation will be a better more
hopeful safer and more livable place
without them
now I'm not arguing that our country
should emulate Singapore in every
respect there are certainly things about
the country I don't like and I'm not
claiming that beating criminals and
hanging drug traffickers would on its
own solve all of our problems I
acknowledge that Singapore has other
advantages they have a smaller much more
homogeneous population for one and that
helps it to build and maintain
communities that aren't littered with
used heroin needles and reeking
constantly of weed and human urine like
our cities
but even so there is a lesson we can
learn here the lesson is that
Civilization
comes at a cost
if we have decided that nobody should
have to pay that price
well then we will no longer have
civilization
we live free and comfortable and gentle
lives and so we imagine
that everything is and should be
comfortable and gentle all the way down
what we don't realize is that this
freedom and comfort and gentleness has
been maintained
by tough men who are willing to do hard
and sometimes ugly things
if we insist now that those things must
not be done anymore because they
interfere with our comfortable illusions
then pretty soon we will no longer have
the Comfort or the freedom
we are surrendering our society to its
worst and most predatory factions
because we're too squeamish to stand up
to them to impose our will over them and
to force them to live like civilized
human beings which is what you're
supposed to do with criminals you stand
up to them you impose your will on them
you force them to behave you don't give
them an option
it's not putting them in jail for let's
hope they reform let's hope they see the
air in their ways and that they choose
of their own free will to be better
people
now we don't sit around waiting for that
well you know our children are getting
murdered in the street we don't sit
around waiting for it we say we're not
giving you an option
and if your crimes are bad enough we're
not going to worry about uh about
reforming you because you're done
there's no second strike
in other words uh
these days we wish to have a
civilization without Justice
because Justice is too harsh a thing for
us to stomach
we say no to Justice which means we say
no to civilization
which means that rather than forcing the
Lawless dregs of humanity to pay the
price
we all have to pay it instead
now let's get to our headlines
a brief programming note some of you
have noticed that episode 1097 of this
show where I discussed the gender
surgeons who want to implant uteruses in
men is now missing from our YouTube
channel and that's because as we found
out last night YouTube deleted the
episode having decided that comments I
made during that discussion were in
violation of their hate speech policies
and I'd say to begin with
in a sense
they're right I I do hate what is being
done by these Frankenstein surgeons and
these new age Nazi scientists who are
conducting horrifying human experiments
um I hate what they're doing to people
that's that's for sure I absolutely hate
it we all should
um it was a speech expressing hatred of
those practices which of course uh I
also don't even remotely come close to
apologizing for needless to say but
YouTube took it down which means that if
you want to watch the full episode and
hear all of my hateful thoughts then you
need to go to a daily wire
dot com and it's all still there and
it's hateful Glory
all right
fox has this report
former vice president Mike Pence
informed Congress on Tuesday that he
discovered documents bearing classified
markings from his time as vice president
in his home in Indiana on January 16th
following the revelations the classified
documents from President Joe Biden's ten
years vice president were found at the
Penn Biden Center Think Tank and
Wilmington Delaware Pence and also
Wilmington Delaware Pence's team
conducted searches of Pence's Indiana
home and the office of his political
advocacy group advancing American
Freedom according to his team Pence
informed the National Archives on
January 18th that a small number of
potential classified documents were
found in two small boxes another two
boxes contained copies of vice
presidential papers the National
Archives then informed the FBI per
standard procedure all right so
I mean at at this point like I feel like
I need to go home and make sure that I
don't have classified documents I guess
we all have them
and if I do have them I would
immediately return them
unless Putin offers a high price for
them obviously and that would change
things
this does just go to show I mean at this
point it's a farce now like it's it's
like everybody has them I I'm I'm quite
certain that if they were to do a check
of Obama's residence which they would
never do
they'd find plenty of classified
documents as well apparently this is
this is something that people do right I
didn't know that but evidently it's what
happens
um and it goes to show
of course that the Trump
classified document story was always
ridiculous
not because it wasn't true
this thing we have to remember about the
fake news media is that yeah sometimes
they invent stories out of whole cloth
and they've certainly done that with
Trump
times that's what they do but usually
that's not how the fake news Works
usually the fake news it's in it's in
the details they're ignoring it's like
what they're saying might be sort of
accurate but it's meant to give a
misleading impression because of the
details they leave out or because of the
things that they choose to emphasize or
because of uh they take a story and try
to try to blow it up and make it a huge
deal while other stories they ignore
it's like that's
slightly more subtle in how the fake
news operates in this case was it true
that Trump had classified documents in
his home no that seems to be true
what's not true is that it's some sort
of
earth-shattering enormous deal that we
all need to be really worried about and
that it indicates that Trump was up to
something deeply nefarious and that he
that he was trying to sell the documents
to Putin or whatever that's the part
that was obviously from the beginning
absurd
and there's no excuse to be misled on
this sort of thing anymore
your BS detector should be refined
enough to pick up on this stuff
as I said I had no idea
that
I'm not terribly shocked by it but I
didn't know that this is something that
presidents and vice presidents
apparently do where they end up with
classified documents I didn't I didn't
know that
until this thing happened with Trump
but as soon as I found out about it even
though I just even though I had just
found out about it I I it still was
apparent to me that well this doesn't
seem like a big deal
the only way that this is a big deal is
if he did have some sort of intention to
sell the classified information on the
black market that's what would make it a
huge deal
but that he just wasn't going to do that
that's not what this was
because we live in reality not a not a
movie
um this is not a Jack Ryan or something
this is reality
and now that's all that's all become I
think hopefully obvious to to everyone
and the left they can't deny it either
because now they know
now it's happened with Biden and they
and they also know that if they were to
dig deeper which they're not going to do
that they're going to find classified
documents in everybody's home
everyone in DC apparently they just uh
they take a
it's like a parting gift I don't know
when you leave you take they give you a
little goodie bag
may they give you some classified
documents you can bring home with your
keepsakes
something to reminisce with I suppose
all right Joe Scarborough on MSNBC
contracted covid and when he came back
to work this was yesterday he expressed
regret that he hadn't gotten his fourth
booster shot to prevent the covet
infection he was disappointed in himself
that he didn't get his fourth shot and
that's why he ended up getting covered
because the first three didn't do it at
first three didn't do it and what does
that mean it means you can keep getting
more of them
uh which is pretty funny and people were
laughing about it which prompted Joe
Scarborough when he came back to respond
to their mockery of him and his response
is also funny let's watch that
you know yesterday when I was talking
about uh getting covered and I and
should have gotten a fourth booster shot
a lot of these freaks go oh fourth
booster shot robot no listen here's the
deal if you get a flu shot
what do you do do you go to the doctor
oh my God you want me to have a 50th flu
shot now you get a flu shot every year
right and as we're finding out with this
pandemic well it lasts six months maybe
a year so yes yes put on your big boy
pants
put on your big girl pants and if you
want to be healthy I don't care if you
don't that's your business smoke
cigarettes do whatever you want to do
stay up all night don't sleep that's
fine
be unhealthy your choice my concern here
though and let me bring in Reverend
sharpen because we've talked about this
my concern rev is that
there's a disinformation out there where
people are saying oh well it doesn't
work because you you've got to keep
getting booster shots the thing is
you're always trying to build up your
immunity
and people are still dying from covid is
it a crisis right now well for the
people who are dying of covet yeah it's
a crisis is it as bad as it's been no
but as a doctor explained to me when I
didn't want to get flu shots you're not
just doing it for yourself you want to
cut this off before uh the Reverend
Al Sharpton shows why are we bringing Al
sharp tonight to talk about he's a
medical expert now about uh about
vaccines
which which they basically dropped that
I mean there's a few things here
to begin with he says everyone gets a
flu shot every year do they I don't I've
never gotten a flu shot in my life
um I've never gotten a flu you know what
I've never gotten a flu shot because
never gotten a flu shot in my life
have I ever gotten the flu yeah I mean I
I've never gotten the flu shot and I've
had the flu I don't know maybe
twice in 36 years
and one of the times it was it was
pretty bad I was pretty sick for about
three or four days
so I've never gotten a flu shot and I've
got the flu twice
well they also fully admit that even if
you get the flu shot you can still get
the flu
so what would we what would my batting
average be if I had been getting a flu
shot every single year
I mean they they would admit that you
need to get the flu shot every year for
36 years you'll probably still get the
flu a couple times well I don't get it
and I get the flu a couple times
so why am I gonna get the shot
but also
this is the game that they're they're
playing now
where now we hear from people like Joe
Scarborough
oh the the shot of the last six months
to a year that's like it's just like the
flu shot you get it you get it every six
months which even that does anyone get
the flu shot every six months
there's a difference there too
um it's a difference of like double the
number of shots
I think most people if they get the flu
shot
on a regular basis they get it every
year
so now now they're saying yeah Jay you
just get it every six months what's
what's the big deal
part of the big deal here
which you hope that we forget is that
that's not what you said at first
that's not how this was sold that's not
how the shot was sold
um
now when I say sold it was not really
sold more like forcing it into people's
arms
which is the other part of this because
he also says well it's your choice if
you want to live an unhealthy life
that's not what you were saying two
years ago
that's what we were saying two years ago
that's what those of us who don't
believe in you know forcing the
chemicals in people's bodies if they
don't want it that's what we were saying
we were saying how do we feel about the
about the vaccine should be your choice
so if you're a pro-vaccine person and
you think that it's really unhealthy to
not get the vaccine
you're allowed to think that
so your answer should be well if you
want to live an unhealthy life then
that's your choice
now they've adopted that attitude uh do
what you want it's your choice
that's not what they were saying before
and they certainly were not saying yeah
this will be just like the flu shot and
uh or or actually even less effective
than the flu shot because this one you
have to get every six months
for your entire life
so if you live 60 more years you're
going to get this uh the the covid
quote-unquote vaccine
120 times that is not what they were
saying
that's what they're saying now and
hoping we don't remember what they
actually said
I want you to hear this exchange between
a reporter and a Karen Jean pair and
this is a wonderful clip because between
the two of them they they may be setting
the record for I don't know lowest
Collective IQ
but let's listen to this together
me and some friends that are in this
country and this I'm making this point
because because we need to remind people
that America is the only country on
Earth that people die by gun without
even being on in war because I'm giving
this example because in Africa there is
countries in up in war but people
doesn't even have access to gun is very
hard because the government and
everybody is very conscious that the
guns can cause a lot of Destruction but
in this country is very normal for
everybody to have access to gun and this
needs to be controlled but what can
people like me common people can also
what can we do to help control gun right
that's pretty positive there for a
second pause it one second before we get
to Karen I want to hear her answer
because she's a very
eloquent articulate person she always
has insightful things to say so I really
want to give her a chance to to answer
that but
um
here's what our answer should be to what
you just heard her answer should be
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
in my life how did you get in this
building what are you doing here what
she actually claims the reporter there
is not from this country claims that
America is the only country in the world
where people die by gun violence that is
not when it's not in the context of a
war
it's just simply
not close to true it's especially not
true in Africa
um but it's not true anywhere
on
God's green earth
is that what Karen G Perry will say well
we'll find out
well look what I can speak to there are
many ways that people can get involved
in in dealing with the gun violence that
we're seeing here I'm not going to make
any suggestions but there are ways that
folks can go out there and and uh and
participate in a way that's healthy in
the way that actually helps deal with a
real issue what I can speak to is what
the president has done what I can speak
to is what the president believes what I
can speak to is the president's record
on this which is you can see for
yourself as a senator this last two
years as president in the executive
actions that he's taken he signed a
bipartisan piece of legislation as I
just mentioned moments ago
foreign
she's great because she's so terrible at
this you know and I and I know and I
don't blame her for the fact that she
can't she can't answer any of the
questions
um she just has to obfuscate all the
time I don't blame her for that that's
what
White House Press secretaries do that is
their job is to their job is to never
answer a question
but you there there's a skill there's
actually a talent there's a there's a
talent involved in um
being a really good BS artist and uh
being asked a question and giving
something that sounds like an answer but
isn't she does not have that skill uh is
so obvious when she's when she is we
can't even say she's dancing around this
is not dancing because dancing gives the
impression of someone who's Artful and
graceful which she is not
so she has no answer to that well what I
can speak to is
what the president has said what I could
speak to is his record
what I can speak to is the president
what I she keeps listing what she can
speak to and she doesn't speak to it she
doesn't say anything about it
um
so that's good something in In fairness
it is it was a really really dumb
question
dumb question not only because the
person claimed that gun violence only
happens in the United States
and dumb not not only because the person
making that claim is from Africa
um where there's certainly uh plenty of
violence of all kinds
but also dumb because it all led to the
question of what could we do in our
individually in our communities to stop
gun violence
there's one thing you could do one thing
we could all do is um
maybe that maybe that part of the
question isn't so dumb because actually
there is something that we can do in our
communities
the two things actually
if you don't want crimes with guns to be
committed one thing is don't commit
those crimes yourself
so the more people who commit to that
the less crime there will be and uh then
the second thing is to
have the ability to defend yourself
and to refuse to be a victim
that's the second thing you can do so of
course she's not gonna say that
all right I don't know why we're gonna
spend any time on this at all but
variety has this report
everything everywhere all at once a
twisty sci-fi Adventure led the
nominations for the 95th Academy Awards
on Tuesday Morning picking up 11 nods it
was followed closely by All Quiet on the
Western Front a World War one Epic and
the Banshees of initial in I think a
Darkly comic look at friendship that
unfolds against the backdrop of the
Irish Civil War both of which scored
nine nominations all three films will
fly for best picture and what is shaping
up to be a much more commercially
successful collection of honorees than
recent years the best picture race
contains the two highest grossing films
of the Year Avatar the way of water and
top gun Maverick along with Elvis a
musical biopic that scored with
audiences last summer other contenders
include Steven Spielberg's the fablemans
tar a drama about an abusive conductor
women talking a look at the residents of
a repressive religious community and
triangle of sadness a send-up of the one
percent that unfolds partly on a mega
yacht so they opened up the best picture
nominations a few years ago so that now
they're nominating
I think they doubled the number of of
films that can be nominated and this is
what you end up with you end up with
some of these Blockbuster films that
were not good
uh I mean Avatar
it it was very good at earning a lot of
money
although it's arguable how good it was
at that considering it had hundreds of
millions behind it in marketing so
really it it had to make over a billion
dollars or it would have been a loss
so one hand you have these films that
like they're only there because because
they made a lot of money and then you
have films that no one has ever heard of
or seen
and there's nothing in between
films that were like legitimately
successful and you know people actually
saw and have heard of
and but also we're we're good films
there's there's that isn't very
represented here
what I can tell you though just to give
the uh
the official answer on this
uh the best movies of the year without a
doubt there's no there's no dispute
there's no debate on this best moves
here All Quiet on the Western Front that
was one of the best movies and that does
that did get some nominations
and then uh and then the Northman was
was the other best movie of the year
but the North End wasn't nominated for
anything and all quite of the Western
Front will almost certainly not win
anything
and the reason on both counts is because
those films are too basically all white
not just white it's like the worst of
all worlds for Hollywood it's these are
films about white people and uh and even
white people acting heroically and then
also almost entirely men in both films
so we can't allow that
they're both among the widest and most
masculine movies we've seen in a while
so no hope of actually winning anything
all right
the daily wire has this report the
College Board the College Board
announced on Tuesday that the curriculum
for AP African-American studies would be
publicly released on February 1st citing
the start of Black History Month the
curriculum has garnered backlash among
conservatives following reports of the
program which is currently undergoing
Pilots at five dozen high schools Across
the Nation as centered upon leftist
activism rather than the study of black
history the Florida Department of
Education recently informed the College
Board that the course's content is
inexplicably contrary to Florida law and
significantly lacks educational value
adding that the state would reconsider
the course should the organization make
the material lawful and historically
accurate the College Board referenced
the beginning of a black history month
and a statement provided to daily wire
announcing the course as structures
public release
saying quote this framework
underdevelopment since March 2022
replaces the preliminary Pilot Course
framework under discussion to date we're
grateful for the okay who cares about
that
um
Florida Republican Governor Ron Santos
who signed legislation last year
preventing the state government schools
from teaching discrimination on the
basis of race color sex has emerged as a
leading skeptic of the new AP
African-American studies course he noted
that it submits policies such as
prison abolition for student
consideration even though such
suggestions are primarily supported by
left-wing activists here he is by the
way we have a clip of Ron DeSantis
talking about this new
black uh Black History Month or
African-American studies AP course and
the problems with it and here it is
this course on black history what are
one what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards we believe in teaching
kids uh facts and how to think but we
don't believe they should have an agenda
imposed on them when you try to use
black history to shoehorn in queer
Theory you are clearly trying to use
that for political purposes
yeah of course and he's absolutely right
obviously and uh there's just no chance
that in uh in the modern age in the
government school system they can have
any course related to something like
African-American studies that will not
be
highly political
uh ideologically charged and yeah
include things like queer Theory
um
because that's that is going to be
that's going to be shoehorned into
anything anything where the left is
involved
um it's always going to come down to
LGBT indoctrination it's uh it is it's
always a forum for that
I mean look at look at BLM before they
change their website
you know originally on their website
when they listed their uh what their
mission statement is
all over their mission statement
it's about trans rights LGBT this LGBT
that
what does that do with black lives
matter
that's because that's a cover for just a
far left agenda as he accurately points
out
though I'll also say that I'm not in
favor of uh you know you hear some
conservatives say well we got to reform
we need to reform this program we need
to take a look at it we need to audit it
and figure out a way to
we don't need this at all okay this is
not an appropriate or relevant thing any
kind of African-American history or
studies that should not be a course that
is offered
or presented in grade school in public
schools it shouldn't be there at all
and why is that because what we should
be teaching kids is American history
that's it the course courses should be
focused on American history not breaking
history down by racial groups
the moment you start to do that it is
again going to automatically become
politically political and ideological
but it's also not appropriate
for a public school environment teach
the kids American history
and that will
include the story of everyone who has
been an American
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Applause]
Bob here says the reporters tried to
contact the 17 year old girl at her
workplace that part should not be
overlooked they're trying to get her
fired
um yeah they're trying to do a lot more
than that the 17 year old girl who stood
up to the uh to the male who entered the
locker room at the YMCA and disrobed
exposed himself to her
um then the media not just calling it a
workplace but they're they're you know
they're trying to publicly shame her
for the crime of um not wanting to be
exposed to male genitalia in the locker
room
it's really Sinister stuff
Luke says the moment Matt said pass down
the fat genes I had to brace myself for
the inevitable pun
the more children he has the stronger
his dad jokes become
I couldn't look
during that segment on Obesity there
were many opportunities for fat puns and
I think that I showed
incredible restraint because I only I'd
say there were about five or six
opportunities I only took maybe two of
them
and I was impressed with myself I was
very proud of myself after that that I
didn't I that I didn't grab every single
pun that one was just too that one you
have to go with
um Aiden says can't believe Matt didn't
laugh at the Obesity expert being named
Fatima
it's exactly my point I wanted to I
wanted to make a comment about that but
I didn't
um
meow meow meow says Walsh's ignorance of
actual science on Psychiatry and
psychology is shocking and yes he is
also right that such a claim can also be
applied to many who challenge him this
is just sad all around PS he's 95
correct on obesity
well
meow meow meow far be it for me to you
know challenge you at all on this but
just simply stating
well what Matt said about this is wrong
that's that's not an argument that's an
assertion
so what what did I say about Psychiatry
and psychology that is uh that not only
is wrong but you say is shocking
especially in the context of the show
yesterday where I didn't I didn't say
much specifically about it
um
other than to
you know make the broad but correct
criticism
that
what the psychiatric industry has been
doing for the last uh several decades
part of the effect of what they've been
doing
is to categorize categorize and catalog
every aspect of the Human Condition
every emotion and behavior and turn it
into a diseasify it disease of disease
diseasifying The Human Condition
and I base that
not on just like my assumption or some
vague feeling
but you can read what they have in the
in the DSM you can in fact you can look
at the fact that they've had five
revisions to the DSM and every single
time they add more things to it
which should already make you skeptical
that every time they keep adding to it
are they really discovering is that is
that really what's happening are they
every year you just discover new mental
illnesses that nobody knew about before
oh but you know I'm not maybe I'm not
being completely Fair
don't just add to the DSM right
sometimes they take things out
but they take things out in response to
political pressure
and when they take things out they very
rarely can give any kind of scientific
reason why they took it out
they just took it out because people
were upset in the classic example of
course is when uh they took
homosexuality which originally the
psychiatric industry uh the the
psychiatrist said was a mental illness
it was in the DSM they took it out and
they took it out because there was a lot
of pressure from gay activists saying
that they were deeply Disturbed and
offended that it was in there
they've also made changes to the way
that uh gender dysphoria is
categorized and certainly how it's
treated in response to political
pressure
this is not ignorance this is just
exactly what they've done
I'm sorry to say
this month we're celebrating the
anniversary of one of the greatest
moments in Daily wire history after
months of us leading the legal battle
against the federal government and the
national do not comply campaign the
Supreme Court ruled in our favor and
blocked the by administration's
outrageous vaccine mandate this mandate
would have set a dangerous precedent
giving the unelected OSHA power over the
personal medical decisions of American
citizens the Supreme Court recognized
this power grab and they made the right
decision and we are so proud to have led
the charge in this fight but we could
not have done it without you thousands
of you joined the daily wire and over a
million Americans signed our petition
against the mandates to celebrate we're
offering 40 percent off on our annual
memberships with the code do not comply
and this is why it's so important that
uh if you're not a member of the daily
wire you consider becoming a member
because
um this is how this is how we fight and
we're in the fight together so to
celebrate celebrate one of the greatest
moments in Delaware history with 40 off
on your annual membership you can do
that right now but you've got to go to
dailywire.com subscribe and join the
winning team as we continue to crush the
left from do not comply for 40 off do
not comply let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well as we know the woke cultists among
us are constantly running a linguistic
inventory scanning through the catalog
of human language looking for random
words to suddenly out of nowhere and for
no intelligible reason declare
problematic and insensitive and this
week the cultists seem to be putting in
some overtime work as there are multiple
examples just from this week of benign
words and phrases being declared
suddenly and indiscernibly offensive but
today we're going to focus only on USA
Today and an article written by
diversity and inclusion reporter David
Oliver the headline asks is it time to
stop saying Aloha and other culturally
sensitive words out of context
not to spoil the ending but uh yes it is
time apparently that's that's what he
wants to tell us he writes quote Aloha
hola Shalom these are ways to say hello
in Hawaiian Spanish and Hebrew
respectively but just because you can
say something doesn't mean it's always
appropriate on the surface simple
greetings and phrases from other races
and cultures may seem fine to sprinkle
into our vernacular inclusive even but
did you know that Aloha doesn't just
mean Hello or goodbye quote it's a
greeting or a farewell but the meaning
is deeper says male Arvin the director
of Pacific island studies at the
University of Utah one of my Hawaiian
language teachers taught it to me as
aloha means recognizing yourself in
everyone and everything you meet if
you're not Hawaiian and you say it it
could come off as mockery that's just
one word to think about the use of
certain words requires education
knowledge and a foresight to understand
when they should or shouldn't come out
of your mouth
yes David Oliver of USA Today will tell
you what should or shouldn't come out of
your mouth
you uh cannot be trusted to Simply go
around speaking and saying words all
willy and Illy you need guidance and
instruction and correction and David
Oliver is here to provide it very nice
of him
something to keep in mind by the way
when considering the subject that we
began the show with today people are
very squeamish about imposing our
Collective will on criminals punishing
them and forcing them to comply with the
law and the standards of basic human
decency but I'm willing to bet that uh
you know David Oliver himself would take
great exception to everything I said
about that subject and yet
these same squeamish gentle tolerant
folks suddenly adopt a quite different
attitude when it comes to normal
law-abiding citizens who say words and
express ideas that they don't like
now it's it's not true then to say that
we live in a permissive Society it's
more accurate to say that we are a
society permissive specifically of
criminals and social leeches but quite
Stern and controlling when it comes to
normal people who do say and think
normal things
now granted David isn't suggesting
caning or executing white people who use
the word Aloha but I'm not sure that he
necessarily objected that suggestion
either back to this article he says of
course not all uses of language outside
someone's culture are problematic quote
we live in a multilingual world where
we're always influencing one another's
language practices uh where we might
come into contact with a variety of
terms or language practices that we have
not grown up in says Nikki Lane cultural
and linguistic Anthropologist intention
matters most dropping hola or Shalom to
someone who you know speaks Spanish or
Hebrew for example isn't something to
worry about
actively Don a fake exaggerated accent
and say those words well therein lies
the problem
yeah but what if the fake accent is
hilarious
can we carve out an exception for
exaggerated accents that are
particularly funny
probably not continuing it says
uh quote like saying Nihao to someone
Asian American who isn't Chinese this
could be both othering and a
microaggression what we need is a
critical Consciousness in our public
around a language says Jeffrey McCune
director of the Frederick Douglass
Institute of African and African
American studies at the University of
Rochester language is too critical to
our culture that we can't just casually
use language in ways that might offend
and or even harm do harm to certain
groups of people it's the larger
cultural considerations around the use
of these words that matter most
quote I don't think the intention is
necessarily to be offensive or anything
but for native Hawaiian people Hawaiian
language was banned in schools after the
Hawaiian kingdom was overthrown Arvin
says considering how difficult it has
been to keep the language alive to see
someone using it without respect is
really difficult for that reason
ah so it's been difficult to keep the
Hawaiian language alive
which is why
you don't want people to use it
there was allegedly an effort to
eradicate the language and now parts of
the language are so common that even
people who are not Hawaiian use it and
that's a bad thing you say
well it's only bad when the word is used
without respect
but what sort of respect do we need to
Grant a word like Aloha what kind of
sacred reverence do you need to see
I'm not sure I know how to respect the
word Aloha even if I cared enough to try
which I don't whatever they mean by
respect the point is that our intentions
are what matters that's what they say
and on that point I actually agree
what matters most in any human
communication is intention
you cannot know how to respond to
someone or how to feel about what
they've said until you understand their
intention behind their words the meaning
they were trying to convey
the words and syllables themselves are
less functionally important in most
day-to-day communication than the
intended meaning behind them somebody
might phrase something incorrectly or
use a word in the wrong way but if you
know what they mean which most of the
time you do then the communication was
successful and only a tedious pedantic
jerk would feel the need to go back and
correct them
the problem is that when the left says
intention is what matters what they mean
to say is
my perception of your intention is what
matters
they don't actually care about your
intention behind your own words
that can be less relevant to them
the words themselves are also basically
irrelevant they will just arbitrarily
decide what your motivations and
intentions were and they will adjust
their level of offense accordingly
but don't worry though they're not going
to leave you entirely in limbo wondering
what you should or shouldn't say and how
you should or shouldn't say it
they won't leave me in that limbo
because I simply don't care at all about
their language rules and I'm not waiting
for their permission to say anything but
if you are concerned about the rules and
and if you are determined to follow them
well our White Knight friend David
Oliver concludes his article with some
very helpful tips here they are quote
these action items will help keep keep
your language in check number one make
an effort to befriend people from other
cultures step outside your comfort zone
and talk to people who do not share our
values or our experiences says Sunni
Rucker Chang associate professor at the
center for Slavic East European and
Eurasian studies at the Ohio State
University
you'll likely get a better feel for
what's appropriate this way two ask
yourself why you are saying the term are
you using the term because you want to
say something besides hello or hey
consider the cultural implications
before you do McCune says is it to the
benefit of laughter and sarcasm and
satire or is it a genuine interest in
being a part of a cultural community
that recognizes the historical meaning
and historical significance of various
terms three remember the weight of words
quote language is really about power
says Rucker Chang and I think that the
person who is using these terms needs to
be more aware of the origins of them
four avoid terms you don't know once you
learn you might decide you you don't
want to use the term because you see
that it is indexing certain things that
have nothing to do with you and which
might reproduce ideas in which you are
not interested in reproducing
what okay five educate educate educate
whether it's history of colonialism and
Hawaii or other significant historical
facts knowledge helps fight ignorance
now one thing they don't cover is um
about what about when I when I
intentionally mispronounce foreign words
and foreign names simply because I find
it amusing to butcher terms I'm not
familiar with
like what about when I is that okay can
I do that
I guess it's not okay that's my guess
which only makes it more amusing to me
which ensures that I will continue doing
it even more as for the rest
um it's all nonsense of course consider
the cultural implications before saying
hello to someone
how is it even possible to function in
society if you have to treat every
conversation like some sort of Explorer
making contact with a primitive jungle
tribe for the first time paranoid that
one wrong move or phrase will result in
a spear through your chest and your
corpse roasting over you know an open
fire for dinner
of course it's not possible to function
that way which is part of the point
these people are very much opposed to
any functional vision of society or
human interaction function is what they
hate most of all and what in the hell
does she mean when she says language is
about power
I mean that's the kind of utterly
nonsensical statement that college
professors make to their students all
the time who are meant to just sit there
and mindlessly consume the nonsense like
baby birds inhaling whatever
half-digested muck is spewed at them if
you sit and think about it though for
for more than half a second you realize
that it makes no sense
and it makes no sense in the most
cynical and hideous way imaginable
because she is casting ordinary
communication
polite greetings between people as power
struggles
when you say hello to someone it's a
power struggle you are you are
exercising power over them by saying hi
she suggests that people ought to bring
their ancestral resentments and blood
feuds into every exchange seeing even a
statement like hello as an effort to
colonize and enslave them
as always then
we find that what appears to be merely
stupid on the surface turns out to be
still very stupid of course but even
more Insidious and hideous than it first
appeared
and this is ultimately why to David
Oliver and SUNY Rucker Chang and anyone
else associated with this article we
must say to all of them
Aloha and you're canceled
I'll do it for this portion of the show
let's move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]